you like getting naked yeah yeah I liked
I've spent a good amount of time naked
yeah yeah but even when you were a kid I
was always getting naked I was always
getting in trouble for getting naked
they're like you can't just pull your
dick out it's like in your sitcom yes
yeah Parks and Recreation the sitcom I
wonder if this is okay I guess it is I
you know basically there was a scene
like in this in the second season of the
show I play this guy who is is
dim-witted and guileless but a real
idiot and-and-and but lovable and and he
lives out in a pit outside of this he
lives in a hole in a tent and he's like
kind of a homeless guy and and he but he
got kicked out of his girlfriend's house
anyways long story short she has invited
him to come back to the house for some
reason but I think it's to hook up so I
come back naked and of course they give
you these briefs that are like like
little underwear but that are skin
colored because they'll pixelate it out
but now I open a knock on the door Amy
Poehler's character opens the door and
says sandy and I'm naked and that's the
bit well it was like late in the day and
amy was going Andy but it to me it
didn't seem like she really was reacting
to seeing my dick drop trou as an improv
she'll open the door and then that will
be the take that they will use right by
the way it is the tape she opens the
door and she goes Andy whoa
and I ran it by the boom mic operator
should I get naked he was like and then
I got a letter from NBC saying basically
never ever do that again there is a
protocol to being naked you must give
everyone the option to not see it the
yes there's not that many people in the
room but there's a camera and behind the
camera is a ton of people watching you
know so I got naked and then and then
they sent me a letter and I framed it I
got it right next I got it in my office
I loved it and it's said it said first
of all this is not a joke
you're being reprimanded this is this is
the last warning
it can't happen again and also we don't
want you going around and talking about
this letter like it was something some
kind of joke in restaurants you oh yeah
oh yeah so you worked in Hawaii but then
you worked in LA as well yes I worked in
at a restaurant in Beverly Hills to
pause it was what tried to be it was a
it look it was a terrible restaurant and
it was it was just awful and I was a
major contributing factor it was it it
was just real garbage it's been revamped
now but I loved it it was the name
give you free meals I mean they will
give me that's how I ate I mean when
you're when you're in Hollywood and in
other places like you need a job that
gives you four days free so you can try
to audition for projects so I'd work the
weekends I've worked the nights and that
would that's the only I did I had no
money and no one was coming to the
restaurant so I wasn't making any tip
I'd make like 20 or 30 bucks a day maybe
and so it was really a place I'd go to
nourishment to eat yeah yeah
that kitchen fed me for like the time
that I was there Isis oh man do you ever
do this where you I would like a lady
would come in and she'd be like what do
you recommend I'm like 32 ounce
porterhouse I said listen here's how you
want medium rare with some mushrooms on
the side year-old woman and so I bring
the steak out to this lady she I'm not
I'm not hiding in the corner watching
like it she's like how much is she
eating and how much do I get you know if
she was like I can't eat another bite
yes the steak is left we have to sing
called the tunnel which is an area
between the dining room in the kitchen
where they keep all the soft drinks and
like the silverware and stuff and that's
I've been busted so many times eating
off people's plates that they were like
you have to stop doing that like it's
really really bad you know so anything I
ate I had to eat in the tunnel my safe
zone the customers aren't gonna see me
eat their food and the chef's not gonna
yell at me for eating the food so it was
like I had about 14 maybe ounces of
steak that I had to get down in about 10
feet
wolf the stake down you know that's the
three days where the protein right
walk back out and the lady was like
listen I'd love to get that steak to go
oh man let me go I'll go check and I was
like Oh what do i do what do I do
and I said I'm so I'm so sorry I already
threw in the trash I threw in the trash
and she said it's for my dog it's fine
just fish it if you don't mind just fish
it out put in the boxes I was like it's
on the fly man don't ask any questions
just give me one right now and so he
started cooking at stake and I was like
[ __ ] I went out to where I was like
ma'am I'm gonna get you that steak they
just took the garbage out to the
dumpster I'm gonna roll up my sleeves
I'm gonna jump in that dumpster I'm
gonna get it for you because what kind
of dog Pomeranian no way I love that so
this week that steak and she ended up
being so like happy that I would be
willing to dig through the garbage for
her dog that she gave me a giant tip and
she left early cuz she couldn't wait for
the steak to be done so I got another
steak and like this is a weird thing so
Chris Pratt is this this seems so
unlikely that you have now learned how
to do the voices from TOWIE yeah sort of
yeah we love that garbage TV crazy about
it and when I was here filming guardians
we shot guardians the galaxy here in
London and my wife on a came out to
visit and she fell in love with this
show TOWIE The Only Way Is Essex it's
this show that's like basically their
jersey shorts the Jersey Shore from from
here it's like this town somewhere Essex
I guess
these folks are just like the worst it's
like I'm a parrot a little bit and so
when I hear when I hear it all the time
I just started picking it up and started
like I could pick up their accent and do
their accent a little bit them anomaly
I'm okay it's gonna sound really
embarrassing to do in front of a whole
room full of Brits here but I'll try it
anyways so it's like mmm so I want to
say like a silly scar
yes they did like like Michael cheat on
me was in a be far and also telling me
is I you know unless you or whatever
[Applause]
okay I need a volunteer
should I doing a card trick for
will.i.am I love my life okay okay so
here's what we're gonna do this is
called burnham and it works 50% of the
time so I'm gonna make three piles
now will.i.am may I call you will I am
yeah yeah okay yeah um take this card
and pick it up and put it on actually no
put it on either side of these piles you
want face up this card right here
Oh take you that car take that card and
put it face up on either side oh yeah I
get a choose yeah yeah and now take that
card and put it put it there face up
hell yeah
now this is your card but do not let me
see it but show everybody okay
that's your conference already see it
okay how much and don't say anything
oh good car and when you're and when
you're finished committing it to memory
put it back in the middle pile anywhere
anywhere anywhere you want in the middle
part hide it and make it so that I could
never know where you okay you got it ya
know ooh two fours I call this trick two
fours i taked 1 4 on the bottom 1 4 on
top now what do I know I know that your
card you remember your card don't tell
me this is somewhere inside this little
deck but I don't know where it is so I'm
gonna put that in the middle let's and
put that right there now I want you to
shuffle that four times oh [ __ ]
now I told you this only works half the
time so if it doesn't work I'm gonna be
really embarrassed okay one shuffle
mm-hmm - shuffles three shuffle but
that's okay let's try now what all great
magician face yeah okay now I'm gonna
look cuz I'm gonna find your car don't
don't don't look at my process wait wait
how many chances you get to find the car
though cuz we can sit there for hours
I guess four oh you get four chances yep
that seems fair
thirty minutes each yes Graham Norton
Show yeah okay let's see here no no
that's not it
oh it's coming it's gonna be here okay
horn I think I got it
nope okay come on have four chances wait
a second
where you count four chances to just
shuffle through them or four chances to
show me you just know you just look at
me something for your card
I'm looking for your card okay I got it
the first chance yeah boom okay
it's called Burnham I take one I burn it
I might have burned your card will.i.am
your card is it your card yeah just tell
me your card now cuz this could be it
what is your card you can tell me now
because I wouldn't be able to take it
out
it's an a an a of har a of Hearts yeah
the ace of hearts rhyme though your card
a a is in this pile
Sam will ah Shazam
wait will.i.am I'm not done give me a
fist bump wait a second magic fist bump
keep it right there don't move it
squeeze
[Applause]
[Music]
you